well good morning I last spoke at this
conference a couple of years ago and and
talked about IOT and today I'm excited
to be back to talk about sort of the
continuing evolution or revolution of
the overall intent architecture and as
Jim said the importance of the edge you
know and we've talked about this coming
flood of devices you know 50 billion
devices connecting driving traffic you
know and the number of devices is an
amazing thing but even more than that
it's not the devices so much it's the
amount of data that is just growing
exponentially you know and I think we've
kind of thought about the Internet up
until this point as being sort of I'm
uploading videos I'm watching videos I'm
using Facebook or Twitter or surfing the
web or whatever and that traffic is
continuing to grow
you know we're expecting to see a
gigabyte and a half of traffic per day
per person by 2020 which is a lot but
that is going to be completely dwarfed
by the data generated by devices and you
know a few examples of that you look at
a connected airplane five terabytes of
data per day generated by that aircraft
every single aircraft a smart hospital
three terabytes of data per day a
connected factory three petabytes of
data per day you know imagine a factory
that's got thousands of connected
devices inside of it and they're all
generating data and you're using that to
improve your processes a self-driving
car he does something that's probably
been talked about more than these other
use cases generating four terabytes of
data per day per car so just an absolute
explosion in the amount of data it's
going to be generated and obviously with
that amount of data being generated you
can't just send all that data to the
cloud and do analytics on it there and
I'll talk about you know there's a
variety of reasons for that beyond the
fact that no matter how fast your
network is you just simply can't
transport that much
you know in that time frame so this is
gonna drive change in some of the
technologies that we're all working on
you know and as obviously I don't need
to tell you open source is the
foundation of the antenna network that
we have today from the devices to the
network to the cloud and that's going to
continue to be true and we've got some
great technology building blocks already
but there's new use cases and new
requirements that are coming and things
that we all need to work on to enable
this evolution to the edge and I'll talk
about a few examples of that and some of
the things we're working on and
obviously looking forward to all of your
collaboration as we work to build this
new set of open-source technologies for
this world to come so cloud computing up
until now you know as you're all
familiar with has mainly been focused
around you know we generate data with
devices my mobile device we send that
into the cloud where it's stored and
then we use compute cycles to do
analytics and extract value you know
lots of examples of this this is the
world that we're all very very familiar
with and as we look forward we're going
to see that sort of storage computation
and analytics capability extend out it's
going to extend out to the edge and to
the things themselves you know if you
think back to those examples I gave of
where this data is being generated think
of the autonomous car is a great example
that's going to start to look like sort
of a mini data center mini cloud on
wheels it's going to have all of those
capabilities to store and do computation
and analytics locally as well as being
connected to the cloud to do other
computation and analytics you know if
you're if you're in a car and you've got
cameras and radar and lidar and you're
gathering all that data you need to make
real-time decisions on how to steer the
car and you can't send that data up to
the cloud and wait for an answer back on
which way to turn no that's just not
going to work right the latency
requirement is way too tight to ever do
that and yet of course you're going to
be using lots of cloud services as well
so you'll have that so
rolling data center device that's kind
of a combined edge device doing a bunch
of computation that architectural II
kind of looks like a data center and
you're gonna need a lot of those same
capabilities but at a different scale
you know if you think about the
connected factory or the connected
hospital you're going to have a whole
collection of devices that live inside
of those environments that maybe aren't
capable of doing a bunch of compute
themselves but you'll see them connected
to local edge devices that are going to
do some local analytics maybe you don't
want to send all of the patient data
into the cloud because of privacy
concerns you're going do some analytics
on that locally and then some of that
data will go to the cloud so we're
evolving to this architecture where
you've got storage computer Netta Linux
distributed across the end-to-end
network and that's going to drive a need
for some new capabilities and new
technologies and why is this coming now
you know I think we've talked about some
of those reasons as these new use cases
evolve the autonomous car or the
connected plane you've got this need for
speed and and latency and locality of
compute that's going to drive you to do
some of these functions at the edge
security and privacy you know maybe I
don't want to send all of my data into
the cloud because there's privacy and
security concerns I want to be careful
and thoughtful about what do i compute
locally what do I share out into the
cloud scalability you know with the
incredible explosion of data that's
being generated you just simply can't
transport all of that data into a
central place you've got to be able to
spread that computation and analytics
throughout the entire end-to-end network
you know which is also related to cost
you know the network bandwidth even with
5g is going to continue to be a precious
resource and so we need to use it
carefully and balance what we compute
locally versus what we send over the
network so we're starting to see this
happen you know this is already starting
to come to be but over the next five
years this is going to become more and
more of a requirement more and more
common you simply won't be able to
deliver these new usages unless we're
able to create this world of an
end-to-end
spectrum of compute and analytics and
storage of data so what kind of
technologies do we need to do this we
have a number of them already you know
containerization and orchestration AI
and machine learning we're using all of
those already and in those cases this is
more of an adaptation
you know we've got great set of building
blocks open source technologies but
these are different use cases different
scale different requirements so we're
gonna need to do some adaptation in
these areas 5g networking is going to be
an essential part of this if you think
about autonomous vehicles and how they
communicate to the network and with each
other
5g is gonna play a very big role in that
and as you heard from our pit there's a
bunch of open source technologies in the
software-defined networking space that
are essential you could never build out
the 5g network using proprietary
hardware and software it's way too
expensive and too slow so open source is
going to play a key role there
functional safety is another I think
really interesting space you know we at
Intel have been working a lot in and
around the autonomous vehicle and we're
seeing this really interesting
transformation you know as the software
workloads inside of the car become
orders of magnitude more complex you
know traditionally the functionally safe
systems in a car and to think about the
the software that's running your
instrument panel and your speedometer
and tachometer for example which is has
to be safety certified those have
traditionally been purpose-built
real-time operating systems really small
footprint simple but the next generation
of cars the software complexity is so
much bigger and the people building
those systems would love to use a fully
featured fully capable operating system
like Linux the Linux is not safety
certified or certifiable today and I
think that's a big challenge for all of
us and we've started to work on this how
do we make and create an ecosystem
around Linux where Linux can actually be
safety certified and deliver all of the
value that we've built in Linux and the
kernel and the core libraries into an
ecosystem that's really eager to have
that capability but can't use it today I
think this is going to take you
for us to actually turn into a reality
or at the very beginning of that
time-sensitive networking again if
you're moving real-time data around a
vehicle for example you need to be able
to do that with latency guarantees and
bandwidth guarantees and then finally
how do we get all of these devices
onboard I'll talk a little bit more
about those as well so let me click in
and just talk about a few things that
we're working on related to this space
so containers now we've been doing some
work on containers for the last couple
of years and particularly looking at the
security aspects of containers so you
know Linux containers you're running
your containers on top of a common
kernel which gives you great scalability
very lightweight but if that kernel is
compromised the security of all of those
containers is at risk so obviously we've
had virtual machines for ever for more
than 15 years and we've built inside of
the Intel platform hardware capabilities
to help make those virtual machines
secure so we had a couple of engineers
our Ian van de Ven and a couple other
folks at Intel that looked at you know
why can't I apply this Hardware
capability against containers and that
essentially is what clear containers is
you know so it's a container that uses
the underlying virtualization hardware
to deliver security that's very similar
to a virtual machine but it's as
lightweight and fast as a container it's
hosted at clear Linux org it's an open
source project and we've actually have a
demo of it out in the in the demo area
if you want to see it in action in terms
of how it can fort some of the kernel
exploits that could be used to attack
containers so a really cool example of
how do I make a container more secure
and take advantage of some of the
underlying hardware capabilities
orchestration we've got orchestration
solutions for the cloud today we've been
working on building a very lightweight
Orchestrator it's called Chow cloudiness
integrated advanced Orchestrator we did
it initially and did some trials with in
OpenStack to show how we could scale up
to very large numbers of nodes in a very
fast time frame but we're really
focusing this on the edge use case now
so how do I create an Orchestrator
that's really well-suited for
it's very lightweight it's kind of small
footprint context rather than a large
data center so another thing that we're
working on developing kind of looking
forward at the edge use case also hosted
on clear Linux org AI and machine
learning we've got some great open
source frameworks already and our work
has been mainly to plumb our hardware
acceleration into those frameworks so if
you're running tensorflow or cafe or
whatever your favorite framework is you
can take advantage of the underlying
hardware acceleration whether that's on
a Xeon or an FPGA or a purpose-built
accelerator and we're going to continue
to do that I think what's going to
happen kind of uniquely at the edge is
you're gonna see these frameworks
certainly running at the edge to do
inference but also combined inference
and training as you start to look at how
do I do more real-time adaptation of my
neural network at the edge or maybe I
have data in my training set that I
don't want to expose because it's
there's privacy or security concerns so
you're gonna start to see these
workloads running more and more at the
edge and also together both the training
part creating the model and the
inference part where you're using the
model and we're going to continue to
work on making sure that these
frameworks run great on top of our
hardware platforms 5g we talked about
coming in terms of driving a great
amount of bandwidth the other thing
that's really unique about 5g is it's
not only continuing to grow the mobile
bandwidth but it's also providing some
really unique new capabilities for both
massive machine to machine communication
and also ultra ultra reliable low
latency communication so you can imagine
if you have a bunch of autonomous
vehicles driving down the road they can
actually use this ultra reliable low
latency flavor of 5g to talk with each
other and to do coordinated actions so
we think this is really exciting you
know we're obviously very actively
involved in driving the overall 5g
standardization but also working on a
bunch of the open source software
defined networking technologies that are
going to be needed to build these
networks going forward time sensitive
networking again inside of an autonomous
vehicle if you're moving sensor data
around in real time just regular old
Ethernet isn't good enough
you need to have latency guarantees you
need to have bandwidth reservation so
you're absolutely
certain that your critical data is
delivered where you need it to go with
the right timeliness so there's been
standards work going on here for a while
in the Avenue group avnu and we were
working in the open Avenue project which
is building out all of the Linux
infrastructure that's required to fully
support time-sensitive networking in a
Linux platform and then finally device
onboarding you know back to this world
of 50 billion connected devices one of
the biggest challenges is how do I get
these devices onto the network in a
secure fashion how do I get them on the
network transparently and with zero
touch so we've been working on some new
capabilities that use a hardware chain
of trust where you can ship out a device
turn it on have it be on boarded into
the network securely and transparently
without any interaction in a way that
doesn't cause security vulnerabilities
you know a lot of times today this is
done using it using a default password
maybe or it requires some human
interaction you know if you're gonna
onboard 50 billion devices there can't
be any humans involved so we've been
working on integrating this with for
example the open connectivity foundation
and the i/o tivity project it's a kind
of an ongoing project to solve one of
the really hard problems in deploying
all of these edge devices securely
across the network so there's a lot of
work going on already in this end-to-end
space and we're involved in driving you
know some of the projects that I
mentioned but also working in many many
of the open-source projects as we work
to evolve the technology to support what
we think is going to be one of the
really big next use cases around edge
computing and I'm really excited to
collaborate with all of you to make that
a reality so we've got as I mentioned in
the booth just outside the door we've
got a demo of the clear containers and
some other cool demos that show some of
this want to make sure you're aware
there's a diversity and inclusion lunch
panel on Thursday really important
subject so I hope you can all attend
that on Thursday afternoon and with that
thank you all very much
[Applause]